I grew up very boy you know it was beat
my brothers were constantly wrecking
bikes no helmets you know idiot
back then but when I see my daughter's
knee and she's going I'm the other way
with it I'm like it's a scrape well not
only that but now let's go back to the
Early Childhood exchange so the child
comes up to the mom and I hurt my finger
and the mom goes oh my God oh my God I
need a drink you make me crazy I can't
you know I need a drink that child then
is not you need a bandit right so so
that child learns that when I have a
feeling my mom catches the feeling and
evokes something that I don't want right
that's where codependency comes from
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
foreign
[Music]